en plus je trouve ça plutôt pas mal de
demandes et les deux créateurs de faire
une chanson est de faire une animation
pour qu'on respecte et j'espère garder
la chance j'ai écouté la chanson j'ai
pensé quoi qu'il vaut mieux faire un
geste barrière donc compris par rapport
à la chanson mais voilà alors il s'est
lâché sur ça et c'est là chez aussi
françois hollande nous a dit qu elle qui
fait comme chanteur et apparemment il
n'a pas les mêmes goûts que jean messia
n'était pas comme eux comme j crew ce
moment j'aime bien la chanson française
le rap vous écouter vous écouter des
choses ou pas si elle est un petit peu
n'ont ils donc j'écoute je suis pas je
suis pas un spécialiste et booba vous
voyez vous écouter vous bah ouais j'ai
vu sa roue bah oui j'écoute booba qui va
sortir un nouvel album à la rupture les
à benjamin biolay mais ça tout le monde
le sait donc ce n'est pas la peine
si c'est parce que ce booba et violet se
connaissent bon oui oui je cottbus bah
oui j'écoute bobin il est très drôle
françois hollande et faut qu'il arrête
de faire n'importe quelle émission
n'importe qui arrivent et n'importe quoi
il y à une embellie sans relogement
regarder le cadre il est sur une vieille
wola on l'a on l'invité d'on btp ses
deux records cc des records mais bon
langage et la non mais c'est très bien
aller chez eux détiennent ces gens c'est
bien mais il ya déjà eu des hommes
politiques qui ont fait des interviews
sur vous sur combiné sait très bien
qu'on vous fait de la télé tout le temps
et que de temps en temps vous faites un
média un peu différent c'est bien le
problème c'est qui va partout françois
hollande m contre lui et je pense que
c'est le dessert sur plan permet à
françois hollande sur la tête de ma mère
demain tu le vois animer une course de
chevaux sur un très bon client est ce
que voulait savoir comment ça s'est
passé
ah oui à l'entourage de françois
hollande qui trouvait que c'était très
bien cette plateforme switch et c'était
plutôt positif
donc ils demandent à samuel etienne de
rencontrer françois hollande ils se sont
rencontrés l'interview s'est très très
bien passé
et comme ça me calme en est finalement
samuel etienne a demandé à françois
hollande de faire cette émission ils ont
accepté ça s'est très bien passé l'a
adoré vous remarqué d'ailleurs capable
de distanciation sociale wilson sont
côte à côte ils ont fait tous les deux
un test pcr away du coup ils sont pas
mieux de pepsi de masques pour être plus
plus tranquille et en fait moi je pense
qu'il voulait parler aux jeunes mais
voilà il avait eu la ville avait la
volonté par le jeune moi je pense
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui dans une
vague de jeunisme un peu ridicule impôts
grotesque ne peut pas lui retirer le
fait qu'il a de la répartie et qu'il a
envie de faire
comme ça n'a pas être différent même
s'ils assurent non mais c'est très bien
qu'il ait fait ça mais c'est vrai que là
il valide aussi sur l'équipe tv
pour ceux qui savent bien aussi mais
c'est vrai qu'il y ait un peu partout et
surtout nulle part non moi j'aimerais
rajouter que en fait françois hollande
est quand même réputés pendant 7 et
petites piques assez marrant que les
harkas il aida recaler les pommettes
mandat et puis surtout que ça un
ex-président quelque part il n'a pas des
comptes à rendre
ben en fait il a des comptes à rendre à
plus de chinois je pensais alors il sait
si la dcri suisse il a des comptes à
rendre à toro il va devoir de réserve
qu'entends tu par rapport à emmanuel
macron puisqu'il a taclé aussi alors
justement regarder il attaque emmanuel
macron voilà de belles transitions
alors j'ai utilisé deux fois le 49 13
une fois parce qu'on a appelé la loi
macron parce qu'on va rappeler pour se
compliquer le jeu il a été votre
ministère de votre mise l'économie oui
vous faites bien de le rappeler mais non
moins presque lui-même peut-être s'en
sont donc je trouve ça ridicule
là il passe vraiment pourquoi vous
trouvé ridicule c'est un ancien
président de la république qui rêve de
redevenir président de la république
d'ailleurs il en parle il dit qu'il
aurait tenté au dernier les débatteurs
que peut être je trouve que là c'est
très exactement je suis d'accord et qui
nie sil respectable tous curieux
république d'accord non plus qu'est ce
qui vous dérange mais pour moi un
président pour moi ça c'est pas
respectable un président il doit être là
il doit opposer n'est pas là pour faire
des blagues
il est là pour diriger les plus
lourdement en contrairement à l'univers
s'est présentée j'ai bien de nous faire
il veut pas se présenter
donc il est aussi vivement à gauche
c'est la sinistrose ya personne
effectivement pourquoi ce serait très
grave s'ils voulaient se présenter pour
moi c'est pas un guignol un président il
dit qu'il a regretté de pas s'être
présenté en tout cas oui et et surtout
ils lancent d'autres pics à macron mais
de façon un petit peu plus sournoise ou
par exemple il dit pour être un
président efficace il faut dormir si
cette heure alors qu'on sait que macron
dit tu ne dormait pas beaucoup il y
lance quand même pas mal sur mâcon sénat
françois hollande c'est comme si si
c'est comme un mec qu'elle jamais gagné
roland garros mais qu il venait d des
conseils au dos
d'autant plus qu'ils manquent de
légitimité depuis le retrait de dsk en
2011 lors des élections comme un jour il
ya un animateur je vous dis null null
null qui a donné un conseil à un autre
animateur qui pour moi est très très
fort et je lui dis t'as qu'à lui à
répondre c'est comme si c'est comme si
même si je les aime beaucoup et wallace
et si l'une est à qu'à lui répondre
c'est comme si même si j'adore c'est
comme si richard gasquet donner des
conseils à federer donc voilà et il lui
a répondu ça et l'autre animateur n'a
pas du tout aimé magnifique ont pu bien
voilà c'est à vous de trouver qui
étaient les nôtres animateur yan un très
très bon et un très très mauvais